Hey, guys! One of the things you've always asked me is what it's like to actually make a video. So, today
I'd love to walk you through the process of
how I'm artistically creative from the beginning to the end. So, I wake up at about 9:30, feed my cats
And frantically go through my journal trying to figure out what the day's video is going to be. At 10 a.m,
Cat, my makeup artist arrives
and I'm still trying to figure out exactly what the video is going to be.
I usually don't have anything written until I'm sitting in the makeup chair probably at 10:30, 10:45,
with the crew arriving at 11 a.m.
Usually, right on the dot of their arrival is when I will print the script and
frantically highlight things to figure out exactly where in my home we're shooting each section.
The crew is great.
Hey, my name is Erik. This is my baby, C. I'm the DoP here on Anna's videos. I am very meticulous.
I like to have things very precise.
(Fuck it.) I will not stop till the shot is absolutely perfect. I'm very demanding of my crew.
[Meghan: How's this, Erik?] Fuck it, it's fine. Eh... Fuck it.
Hi, I'm Kat. I do makeup for Anna's videos.
It's a pretty fun gig.
I mean, it's a lot of work cause you're always touching up, and, you know, sometimes
I wish I had more down time to sit and just hang out.
She's a little lazy, you know,
um -- kind of exactly like a cat, actually -- so, I really quite like it. She lounges around and hangs out with the cats.
I have a back massager that she's frequently using between takes. I normally have to be like, "Hey, Cat,
like, I need your lipstick touch-up" or something, and then she'll finally come in after a minute.
(I'm good.) Hi, I'm John. I, uh,
I help on set as a sound grip, which... isn't... actually a position,
but, I don't say anything. They- they're very accommodating to feed me as much as I want, so it's not bad gig.
He can eat a lot. For a while, I thought he was actually like a Kobayashi in disguise;
he was just kind of doing this on the side for fun.
But it turns out that he just has an insane stomach or tapeworm problem or something.
I have told him he should probably get it checked. He's dating Melissa. Hi. My name is Melissa and
I have a lot of fun at these shoots.
I especially have fun working with John.
I really like the other girls. They-they talk a lot.
And I think we get along pretty well. Hi, my name is Reed. I do some producing for Anna.
I really just try to be helpful as much as possible on set and I think the person that appreciates it the most is probably
John.
So what do you think about Reed?
[Reed: Lunch is here.] Okay, that's lunch. Everyone, break.
He always brings us lunch. So, we have our own little call.
When we- when we want food. It's mostly like, "REED! REED!"
It's usually, like, a bunch of us. Like, Cat and I was like right. It's like,
"REED! REEEEED!"
So that's how we kind of like... Like a baby bird kind of calling for its mother out of the nest.
Hey, everyone! So, I'm Meghan.
I'm, uh, part of the crew on Anna's videos.
How do you like working with Meghan?
Um... I think you mean "Melissa". I don't think we have a Megan on the set. Who?
Who?
Well, uh, I guess I enjoy working with myself, cause... I'm Meghan?
What do you think about Meghan?
Meghan is...
You know, they say, "Keep your enemies close"?
(intense staring)
We go through an entire day,
film a bunch of stuff throughout the house and.
At the end of it, Eric will take the footage and go edit it
then send it to
lovely Bethany Radloff who adds the graphics and then, it gets to you usually about a week or so after we film. I
wish that the process was not this way. You think it's a joke. But, for real, this is how we we shoot this shit.
I'm Anna Akana. Bye!
Aaaand... Action.
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode.
Squarespace has beautiful, award-winning templates. Not to mention, an all-in-one platform.
So, there's no installs, patches or upgrades, ever.
They have 24-hour customer service if you need them in the middle of the night.
And, they offer a simple and unique set of experience if you need a domain.
Squarespace is great for any kind of website
whether you're an artist, a photographer,
Or just need a place to put all your thoughts. Go to squarespace.com
to start your free trial today and use the offer code ANNA for 10% off at checkout.
Squarespace.
Cool. Cut.